hey everyone and welcome to another hd
tutorial in this video i will be showing
you how to get and download a free
dictionary application as well as a
thesaurus application
uh that'll work on your windows machine
so basically what this is is it's an
alternative to uh maybe your built-in
uh maybe you go to dictionary.com for
maybe if you're you have a project and
you need to look up a few words and
define them etc um here is a much faster
way to find your
definition or your synonym
so i'll give you guys the download link
it's a cnet.com or a pc world download
so it's very obviously quite reliable
just go ahead and paste it in here so
this is going to be the sages english
dictionary and thesaurus it'll store
uh basically all of these words and all
these definitions and synonyms in only
eight and a half megs on your hard drive
so this is really really great um it's
basically uh it's basically a
comprehensive dictionary and thesaurus
that is uninvisible for students in my
opinion so in order to get this uh just
right click on the link in the
description and open it in new tab and
uh you can follow the audio here i'm
going to hit the download now button
and it'll say thank you for downloading
and in a second it should come up with
the download here we go the download
window
open
and that was fast 8.3 megabytes are
downloading already
select installer
all right here's your installer we're
just going to open the dot zip file
and when this is done opening we're
going to exit out of safari and whatnot
so we just have this it's just going to
be the sage setup and it's an
application we're going to extract all
files
and we're going to extract it to a place
we can remember something that's not in
the way
i have a specific folder for these types
of things so i'm going to save it there
and make sure you check the box that
says show that says show extracted files
when complete
hit extract
and when this is done extracting you
should come up with a folder exactly
where you saved it so we're going to
scroll down to find exactly the um the
name of the setup file that we just
saved it to
so let's look for
the sage setup double click on it and if
you don't have uic or if you have
disabled uac it will not pop up but if
you have it still enabled then it wasn't
visible to the screen recorder but it
did pop up so we're going to hit next to
continue within this installation we're
going to accept the agreement
we're going to
we're not going to put a shortcut
everywhere we're just going to put a one
and a start menu so we can find it
whenever we want
and then to hit install and we're going
to i'm just going to pause this video so
you guys can come back right when the
installing is done
all right now it says the sage has been
configured successfully so i'm going to
close this and it says installation
complete
so i'm just going to hit next
and it says it has been installed on my
computer so click finish to run this
wizard and then run the sage i left that
box checked so here it is
um
i don't actually have a full screen
application uh screen recorder going on
but you can see it's very very intuitive
i don't want to search definitions i
will just uh search let's see
uh cata
catapult
maybe that's how you spell catapult and
hit the look up button
and here we go it'll say did you mean
catapult that's exactly how you spell it
i just double clicked it and it says bam
it's a noun and it gives me the exact
definition this is a really sweet um
application and a great um
uh how do i say this a great alternative
to dictionary.com and searching and
fishing around
so now i would have down in the verb
version if i want to search cat just hit
enter just like you're searching google
and it was extremely fast i don't know
if you can see how fast it came up but
i'll search
uh
wiki bam and it comes up quite quickly
so
that is that is the application for you
you can also use your internet browser
to go online and search you can um
search similar words and you can also
look up on double click which is what i
already have enabled
this button here says you can enable
concord answer
i have yet to figure out what that is
but i will definitely get back to you
guys on that software part
and then here we have
just basically the definitions now up
here you have the history of what you
search i can exit and delete parts of
the history if i want so that's really
convenient
and on the right hand side we have a
menu button and if i hover over it it'll
tell me exactly what it does this is the
options dialog
this right here is the information yes
this is to view the documentation
tweak the graphical user interface by
the way this is very customizable
next this button is the click to view
the information dialog and last but not
least uh so we have the hide it in
system tray which is also convenient
here is the actual icon
down here in my system tray
and up here all the way on there to make
sage the topmost window icon
so there we go that is basically my
limited software review and i will
definitely do a much more in-depth
software review of the sages english
experience thesaurus so thanks for
watching guys if you have any other
tutorial ideas for me or software
uh ideas for me to review even hardware
go ahead and make your suggestion just
by subscribing and sending me a message
so uh thanks for watching subscribe
peace